I heard about this Shadow document
apparently you and several others cut
some kind of deal or finally got
McCarthy to cave in and give you guys
something then we heard there's going to
be a floor vote to abolish the IRS just
just just tell us what's going on
because you know we're getting it all
second hand
look we believed that Washington was
broken the normal system of selecting
leadership in both parties is based on
the redistribution of lobbyists and
special interest money like if you want
to be the leader of your party you
basically have to raise and redistribute
north of 100 million dollars and Kevin
McCarthy was so good at that he raised
and distributed about half a billion
dollars over the course of the last
election cycle and so it creates a
covenant that's not really built on
trust or Merit or Vision but
trading money for political support
and we wanted to send a shock to that DC
cartel system and say no guess what
there's going to have to be a different
way you get there and the concessions we
sought principally fell into like three
buckets
policy we wanted specific bills coming
to the floor we wanted commitments on
when they would come to the floor we
wanted uh adherence to specific spending
levels with a budget resolution and the
organizing principle of our policy goals
was really to make sure that we would
never again get an Omnibus Bill like we
had to vote on there's just a total joke
of a way of governing like how can we
sit here and honestly say that bills
that are thousands of pages of long
that's been 1.7 trillion dollars and
that you get 48 hours before having to
cast a vote is really legislating it's
not it devalues each individual member
and it's insulting to our constituents
to suggest that we even know what the
hell we're doing when that's the way we
We Run The Railroad
so we had policy concessions second was
procedure you know having those 72 hours
to read the bill having open amendments
like it's the youngest member of
Congress was not yet born the last time
the appropriate Appropriations process
went through regular order and that just
means like we should vote on the defense
stuff separately and then vote on like
the education stuff and then the Health
and Human Services stuff and that it
doesn't just all get mushed together so
somebody can vote for a bunch of
[ __ ] that you wouldn't otherwise
approve and then say well I had to vote
for it to fund our troops right that's
the game that's what the cartel builds
and lobbyists make a gazillion dollars
off of that the final leg of the stool
is Personnel like in order to enforce
the deal that we got we wanted specific
people on specific committees in
specific leadership posts and you know
what's the saying you rob the banks
because that's where the money's at well
we wanted
far more representation on the
Appropriations Committee because that's
where the money is and a lot of
Americans don't know what the rules
committee is or why that's important but
it totally governs
what we get to vote on and what we don't
get to vote on and so we demanded
specific people and specific
representation on the rules committee
I think we're going to be in a lot
stronger position as a result like the
critique I heard a few critiques during
this process one is like this was chaos
you showed the country you know how how
rough and tumble this is and you know
you should have done this behind closed
doors to hell with that man behind
closed doors is where the American
people have been getting screwed and so
I wanted to level my complaint on the
house floor specifically I wanted to
cite the people that I was objecting to
and their Ascension to leadership and uh
so I didn't buy that didn't mind and
then like it's like oh no this took this
you burned your whole first week there
are days in Congress where the only
thing we vote on is the renaming of one
post office
there are days in Congress where the
only thing we vote on are the rules that
govern the next vote
and we take six weeks off every year for
summer vacation where we do absolutely
nothing so to take four days to say this
is the policy this is the procedure this
is the Personnel that is going to drive
the Republican team going forward seems
like the best use of time since I've
been there so that was the the general
construct I mean that's that's amazing
why was it only 20 members of Congress
willing to stand up well I mean first of
all the the front line members even the
front line and when I say the front line
members I mean members that are in
districts that are 51.49 maybe even
districts that Joe Biden won by a
substantial portion right
they had a loyalty to Kevin uh and an
argument that was something like this
well Matt if a guy goes out there and
spends you know four years taking money
from the lobbyists and giving them to
giving that money to us and then in the
last minute you knife that person no one
will ever agree to be the valet for
those people ever again and we need that
delivery system of resources and so like
it's not about how much we like or don't
like McCarthy it's about a system that
we rely on to Resource our campaigns and
I mean that's a pretty astonishing
argument but it it at least has a
logical construct and then you know
there are there are people who
fear disrupting the system they think
look I got here to Congress I've got a
staff that tells me I'm always losing
weight and my jokes are funny like I go
home and I'm the the big cheese at The
Rotary Club and like to every extent
that I can have calm Waters the better
and anything that creates turbulence I
oppose and that's actually a pretty big
swath of the Republican conference and
the Democrat conference that that is how
the unit party gets to group think yeah
and like I hear all this time these like
these geriatric Senators talking about
like all the importance of
these great bipartisan achievements but
so often in my life like the greatest
moments of unity have been the worst for
the people there's a [ __ ] ton of unity
to pass the Patriot Act yeah that's that
that thing we never thought it was
actually going to be used against
Patriots we thought it was going to be
used against you know Arabs and Far Away
lands you know there was a whole lot of
unity over the Iraq War everybody was
for that there was a ton of unity for
the coveted lockdowns there's a ton of
unity for just printing money and
sending it to people that weren't
working and so like whenever they're the
bills that are like the major bills that
have 90 95 support that's when you need
to be most worried at times you fear
retaliation
no because we built the tools in that
would that would allow us to have the
accountability I mean Nancy Pelosi is
going to go down in history as the last
of the Imperial speakers that
centralized power and that then you know
only doled out to members oh well you
can go rename a post office you can go
create a task force meanwhile the macro
economic decisions the major cultural
and policy decisions all get centralized
in the speaker's office where a lot of
the staff all went to like Northeastern
schools and are afraid of things like
fried food and guns and you know people
who enjoy those things right and uh Paul
Ryan gave an interview on CNN yesterday
that was really telling where he even
confessed like I had too much power as
Speaker like way too many of those
decisions were made without the people
who had spent years analyzing policies
uh seeing which programs had varying
levels of efficacy and so while you know
McCarthy I think to his credit at the
end of the day was willing to devolve a
lot of that power
we reinstituted the one member motion to
vacate the chair so for any reason at
any time any member can go to the floor
and call for a vote and to remove the
speaker of the house and if 218 people
vote for that motion then the speaker is
gone now I don't want to use that I
don't intend to use that but I think
having it on the books is healthy for
the institution so that there isn't fear
of retaliation for doing what's right
yeah it is the speaker works for us we
the people and it should be on a whim
taken out I mean I think that those
people are there to represent us if
they're not representing I should be
removed instantly I love that idea thank
you I mean they should at least read the
bills right if you're going to pass a
bill if you're going to pass a law read
to them for freak six one one of man one
of the things Ian's brought up is that
it should be illegal to Pat to vote to
vote on a bill that you didn't read what
do you think about that well I mean then
we wouldn't be taking many votes I mean
it's good you know for yeah exactly I
like that you know that there was a
moment during all this where people were
like well Gates if you you and your 20
hold out stay that way then we won't
even be able to organize and I'm
thinking I'm thinking well give us a lot
of Leverage on the debt limit you know
if we if we didn't constitute the house
so yeah maybe sometimes like you know uh
a reflexive legislative body isn't
what's good for the country yeah maybe
less government is good which which I
think historically that that point has
proven many times over and over again
but I think it's fair to say that there
was also a lot of contention between you
and a lot of other people I know Donald
Trump was also calling in specifically
can you get into some of the contention
that was happening there because it
looked pretty intense it looked pretty
crazy and there was also one specific
photo of you sitting there and there was
a guy in your face and it was a famous
video
um and a famous picture that had the
caption this is how we know uh the Deep
State exists and you were kind of cool
and standing your ground there can you
tell us what was happening there behind
the scenes well first of all I don't get
rattled when people yell at me in public
because it happens like three times a
week so for a lot of members of Congress
like having your colleagues like upset
at you or yelling at you like that's
deeply uncomfortable and really that did
not affect my my week at all because
what I knew is that our argument about
how corrupt and how flawed the
decision-making is in Washington was
getting out and that it was and it was
breaking through
I think the contention was overplayed
because of the cameras look a lot of
times like the the late Don young almost
like pulled a knife on Me on the floor
because I wouldn't vote for a bill that
he had regarding like sea lions or
something like that you know and so
there there are always contentious
moments but usually if you just have
that one C-SPAN camera angle and not the
dynamic angles to see how people are
interacting you don't capture a lot of
it so look you know anybody where you
got 435 people you got a variety of
different alliances and opinions and
grievances that change over time I think
that one of the interesting Arguments
for term limits and I'm very glad we're
getting an actual vote on term limits
because everybody talks about it in
their campaigns but when every vote on
it is that like the churn ensures that
long-standing Boomer grudges don't
become a governing principle it's like
now if you know somebody who's the lead
person on financial services or on the
Ways and Means Committee just hates you
like you're not going to get your idea
through and they can just Outlast you
whereas in a term limits environment
those grudges dissolve every time the
Congress turns over the legislative body
turns over
you mentioned the debt ceiling a little
bit ago you guys are about to vote on a
debt ceiling in the next four months so
I my whole life I've been watching them
incrementally raise the debt ceiling
over and over and over and the thing is
it's from my point of view it's supposed
to be a ceiling that you don't print
more money than that because that's the
ceiling so can we like make a realistic
debt ceiling of like 1.4 quadrillion
just say we're gonna get there
eventually we we can survive this amount
we're going to print another 7 000
trillion dollars
um because I think we are going to I
don't know do you think maybe we won't
um do you what do you think about that
idea is that just too far out what are
you in well you're you're right that
it's it's a joke because there is no
real plan to ensure that we have a cap
on that which we will borrow and spend
and I think the reason this continues to
get worse on the books is because like
regular Americans don't feel the pain of
the national debt in approximate way
like if an illegal immigrant you know
runs over your family member you feel
that right if you know you of someone in
your household loses their job there's a
direct impact you see if the factory
that your mom worked at goes to you know
Chihuahua Mexico that is a traceable
thing but so long as we're the global
Reserve currency we're able to sort of
um
exist in this era of expanding debt now
we're starting to pay the price with
Rising inflation but you know the there
is no real Lobby or special interest for
Less spending in Washington like that's
the problem go on K Street throw a rock
and you're going to hit someone who's
paid a lot of money to get more spending
in one way or the other and so like the
way we compromise is just by doing all
of it whether it's defense non-defense
discretionary non-discretionary
mandatory and that is how like the
uniparty works so the
demand we put with the leverage we had
in the speaker's race was that the House
of Representatives must pass a budget
resolution at the 2022 spending levels
so roll this thing back a couple years
and it's similar to like in 2015 when
they did cut cap and balance and so here
all of what we do has to go under those
spending levels and look it's going to
mean Some Cuts in areas that I support
like defense but if we've got to cut to
fence maybe we ought to cut all the
money we spend defending other nations
far away like Ukraine thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time